on attirait et on a pointé à trappes
sous un soleil quasi estival la commune
accueille ce week-end le championnat
départemental de pétanque au terrain
rené calque un rendez vous attendu par
les puristes illinois des amis mais tous
cas ce qu'on fait c'est vraiment la
compétition
au programme aujourd'hui un championnat
triplettes mixtes etc de boules pour
chaque joueur présent pour réussir à
remporter la victoire tous les boulistes
ou leurs techniques pour bien jouer dans
tous les cas même si on sait on joue un
peu moins des gens un peu moins moins
fort on va dire faut dans tous les cas
fossé boueux s'applique à rester
concentré toujours sa demande du mental
ça demande de la patience il faut être
diplomate fair play et avec les
adversaires
ça demande aussi avoir de l'endurance au
niveau physique parce qu'on en fait 10
km dans une journée
faut être adroit
la journée s'est ensuite terminée par un
pique nique géant entre tous les
participants
c'est aussi ça l'ambiance pétanque